hi welcome I just realized I don't know
if we did a sound check my mic sounds oh
it's so glad to see everyone here I love
doing book events because you know we've
got to keep books alive science books
science books are the best I want to
thank the Symons foundation for
supporting all of our initiatives here
where we do live events and private
events that are science themed or
science inspired and it's really with
their support that we're able to do
these events so we're excited shout out
to the Simons
I want to mention before I introduce our
guests that the amateur astronomers
Association of New York will be out in
the cold garden okay we're gonna applaud
a lot tonight it's out going to be out
in the cold garden tonight with
telescopes and helping us view the skies
and the claim is that that the clouds
will clear right about exactly as we
finish the last question and also we'll
have a book signing for the glass
universe so we'll have a book signing
over here and and we'll do a little Q&A
after our conversation so let me
introduce our guests I'm sure a lot of
you have heard of our gastrin air I
guess so I wanted to do save a sobel
daiva sobel is a best-selling author a
superb writer I remember when I once
heard you speak about your book
longitude you said I think it was your
son asked you what you were working on
and you started to strive did I really
think anybody was going to read it yeah
he was like nobody's gonna read that mom
totally best-selling wonderful book went
through the roof and most recently of
course Galileo's daughter was also a
very popular book and and more so was
acknowledged with the Pulitzer Prize
nomination and was that 2000 so that's
quite an honor and most recently we have
the class universe which is what we're
here to talk about tonight which is the
story of the women of the Harvard
College Observatory we'll be talking
about and so let's welcome to Ava who's
never been here
planetary works and we also have Lea
Halloran my pal
also known as an assistant professor of
art and director of the painting and
drawing department at Chapman University
Lea is a wonderful artist and by just
great sort of synchronicity has worked
with the very glass plates that David
wrote about in in her historical book so
we're really lucky to have them and
they're very different perspectives one
as an artist and one as I don't know if
it's fair to call you specifically a
historian but but very much so I think
in this book do you mind being called a
historian you'll take it yeah history
like just happy
historian so let's think Lea welcome Lea
I I did a terrible thing I didn't bring
my clicker
can you guys advance the slides when I
ask you to or can somebody run up into
my bag and finally clickers on the
second floor oops sorry we're a little
rough around the edges here so let's
talk well can we go actually back to the
first slide for a second let's talk
about this picture so this is we were
going to tonight's conversation the
glass universes is so named because of
the glass plates the tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of thousands of
glass plate
five hundred thousand blades five
hundred thousand and seven plates that
the women of the Harvard College
Observatory used was very innovative
technique to study the universe and well
many things are interesting about it
just scientifically which we'll talk
about
but of course obviously sociological II
this is before women had the right to
vote and you know I used to hear this
story about Pickering's harem which I've
relayed this gaggle of women allegedly
that worked for Charles Pickering the
director of the Harvard College
Observatory and the story I had heard as
he was so disgusted with his mail
computers which was the name for people
who computed astronomical calculations
that he said my scotch maid could do a
better job and allegedly fired all the
men and hired his Scott
made who did a fine job apocryphal tales
it was so what is the real story I mean
part of the real story the real story is
he he already had some women computers
he also had a Scottish maid who had come
to work for him on the resident side of
the observatory as a pregnant woman no
longer with her husband as you said in a
delicate addition she's abandoned by her
husband and he immediately realized that
she was too intelligent to be working as
a maid as a domestic servant so he moved
her to the observatory and gave her
copying work computing work to do then
she went on to become the first woman at
Harvard to have a university title she
was the curator of astronomical
photographs so and Pickering here was
she hired well it depends how you count
so she she came to him around 1879 so he
had been there only two years and then
she had to go home to have the baby come
back so really they list 1881 as the
year she started and William inna
Fleming William inna Fleming yes I and
he is not in the shoutouts from the
audience is this picture was taken in
1925 so she is no longer there she had
died but a lot of famous folks are in
this picture including Annie jump cannon
who started at the observatory in 1896
which one's Annie yeah she is seated
next to the globe okay and she's looking
down mm-hmm now Annie jump cannon was
became famous for her classification
stars so when you learn the types of
stars you learn Oh be a fine girl kiss
me and that's because of Miss cannons
classification so so the acronym I like
there's a start a no star and a no start
and an absolutely horrible well they
were in alphabetical order to begin with
then characteristics of the stars
required
a juggling of the alphabet and so that
mnemonic helps people remember the types
but also in the picture is Cecilia pen
gap Ashkan she is the woman sitting at
the drafting table and she was the first
person to earn a PhD in astronomy at
Harvard but this is important she was
the first person not the first astronomy
PhDs at Harvard went to well the early
graduate students were women because of
this history and it's because of
Pickering well Pickering had already
died when the education program was
started his gathering of a great number
of women to work there and his
befriending of wealthy women who paid
for the research and who also paid to
establish fellowships for young women to
come and work at the observatory for a
year and then they could go out and work
somewhere else mm-hmm and I thought it
was amazing that I remember I had to
keep rereading this in your book to make
sure I was understanding it correctly
that the first PhDs in astronomy at
Harvard went to cecilia payne right and
who you just said and and i remember we
reading it i did you mean the first
women like i kept struggling with it to
think that the astronomy program didn't
exist and the expansion was to include
men right and and she was also the first
chair of any the first female chair of
any department at Harvard so she goes on
to teach at Harvard in the Astronomy
Department and actually oversee the very
first male PhD candidates and then what
is it 40 years later she's awarded as
astronomy chair now there was a lot of
resistance though to hiring giving them
titles other than computer or assistant
computer assistant was kind of a
euphemism even though they were
mathematicians or astronomers well men
could be computer yeah and assistants -
yeah so let's see the next slide who do
we have in this slide I mean as many
wonderful people in the previous slide
but well standing at the back overseeing
the work is William Mena Fleming the
woman we were talking about at first so
she supervised the other women and she
hired a lot of other women but she
started were there as many
female computers the the great expansion
of the female staff happened because of
the Draper's so Anna Palmer Draper was
planning to do a serious project with
her husband he died at age 45 and she
wanted to see his work completed so
being an independently wealthy woman she
offered to give Pickering the money to
carry out the research program in
exchange for having the program named
for her husband I mean but this was
lifelong she continued continued let's
talk about Pickering himself where's
where's Charles Edward Charles he was
about 30 years old in this picture when
he took over at the observatory
a physicist and that was kind of a
scandal why were they hiring a physicist
to run the observatory and how many
years was he there it was 42 mm-hmm now
it's it's interesting because I I was
very moved by this in the story that he
hires this woman in a compromised
position as you say to be a maid and
Pickering you know I think about the
idea of him as some kind of feminist in
a strange way I mean I don't think he
could hypothesize about women breaking
boundaries but if he simply saw the
talent he accepted it it seemed without
any hesitation do you think that's
affair absolutely and he was also not
only hiring women but encouraging the
alumni of the women's colleges yeah to
work on their own and then send their
results to Harvard for publication to
prove that higher education was of value
Lea you you've also looked a lot at this
histories yeah and he also encouraged
women to publish under their own name so
it was like if you were a computer
working at the observatory you're really
part of a bigger picture that of
research that was going on but whenever
discoveries were made he would encourage
and even push different women to be
noted as first in the Harvard annals and
what they were publishing each year he's
give them credit yes
to respond to those things just easily
just with no kind of weight of some kind
of social burden but interestingly he
still had pretty severe limitations I
mean he said things like and I'm quoting
from from your book daiva where he says
you know women with a knack for figures
could be accommodated in the computing
room where they did a credit to the
profession which is a very strong thing
to say but he preface --is that by
saying while it would be unseemly well
I'm quoting you not him but while it
would be in seemly Pickering conceded to
subject a lady to the fatigue not to
mention the cold and winter of telescope
observing and then he goes on to say
women with a knack for figures could be
computers so he couldn't conceive of
them actually operating the Scopes but
that he changed because when Miss Canon
came she she was the first woman to use
the telescope's yes that's and she was
open to that well I was just going to
say that he kind of saw them as being
very valuable but he also didn't
financially value them equally as the
male computers and I think that's a
really important part of this story that
on one hand he's sort of saying you know
this is a great opportunity for you and
for women that are getting out of these
the rise of women's colleges but at the
same time the Harvard computer the
female computers are paid less than half
of their male counterparts for doing the
same amount of work yeah I actually have
the numbers here was it 25 cents an hour
they were paid and actually David in
your book you I think you use the that
you can times it by 285 to get the
current amount and I did the math at one
point in something like these women were
making like $6 and 16 cents an hour but
they're male so I think it was it came
to 1,500 a year not scaling up for
inflation and where the men were paid to
the men who had not been fired I guess
unlike the apocryphal story were
garnering 2500 per years so they were
she was completely in support of unequal
gender page is kind of fascinating and
and Willie Mena fighting complains about
it she's clearly very fond of him but
she keeps a diary and names her son
after him as well
that's right wait Edward or Charles or
what did she name them Pickering he was
Edward Charles Pickering Fleming Wow
she goes back to Scotland to have this
baby out of wedlock and she names her
baby after the observatory director I
mean that's pretty significant about how
much she admired him I got the sense
that most of the women of the
observatory really were quite devoted to
him in a lot of ways that they felt they
were a very collegial group they would
they worked in close quarters six days a
week and then they all socialized on
Saturday night that's tough I mean it
has to be admitted that some of the work
was toilsome I mean yes I mean once we
get to the slide where it has all the
numbers insane hours and incredible I
mean there was a good deal of tedium
involved in the tasks and you never get
the sense I mean you get the sense that
they're fatigued at time so you never
get the sense that they're ungrateful or
that they're resentful of this labor
no I they were well aware that they were
involved in groundbreaking research and
they felt including Pickering that
science was more important than these
other luxuries or other sort of things
that we value socially and Pickering
even his attitude towards these women
was very much one I felt from reading
your history that it was that science
was going to benefit from the this work
and it made no sense to be concerned
about anything else
about whether they were women I've made
no sense at all and yet he did pay them
much less sir I'm gonna read this from
the diary
Wilhemina Fleming's diary she writes he
seems to think that no work is too much
or too hard for me no matter what the
responsibilities or how long the hours
but let me raise the question of salary
and I am immediately told that I receive
an excellent salary as women's salaries
stand does he ever think that I have a
home to keep and a family to take care
of as well as the men and then she says
but I suppose a woman has no claims to
such comforts and this is considered an
enlightened age she said so this energy
was written
right before the women had the right to
vote she was living in and but what's
very interesting is that this is a
really crucial point and you know we we
still live with this legacy of unequal
gender pay women have to support their
families choose very deeply rooted in
our history this idea and also she
starts to feel that her work although
she's told over and over again how
valuable is must not be a value of she's
not paid equally so I thought that was
very strong did you read her journals at
all Leah have you seen her journals I
went when I was looking at the archive I
was so focused on the visuals that I was
drawn to the Annie jump cannon
scrapbooks and archives because it's
like this amazing lineage and history of
scrapbooks that Annie is cutting out of
the current newspapers where they're
getting all this credit and so the story
that I heard the same story that you
heard that they were really
unappreciated in their time story flips
very quickly when you see that there's
this kind of seemingly unending source
material of newspaper clippings from all
over the world of recognition of these
women but at the same time when
Wilhelmina Fleming passes away and her
successor Annie jump cannon becomes the
curator of the astronomical plates the
president of Harvard refuses to give her
that title and she has no the different
president yeah that's right it's not
until the new president that she assumes
this this acknowledged position so she's
known worldwide and had set the
classification system of stars that we
still use today but at the same time
astronomers are writing to or in you
know speaking openly that the president
itself himself is not even recognizing
this brilliant scientist you know within
the corral at Harvard so I was really
fascinated by Annie jump cannon in the
way that she visually recorded all of
her travels to all these incredible
observatories and eclipses and comets
hunting and she was relentless there's
so many great pictures of her on horses
you guys
I'm sorry I don't have any of those
pictures can we see the next slide
though so here actually is an actual
glass plate and and people who doesn't
women typically worked in pairs one of
them would be looking at the plate and
speaking allowed her observations to a
recorder who would write things down and
so the glass plates what was so
innovative about the technology of using
a glass plate I mean we think of doing
astronomical observing old-fashioned way
we think of using emulsions and almost
photography was the photography so these
were glass negatives and Pickering's
genius was to create this photographic
archive which still exists as Lea
pointed out all half-a-million glass
plates are today in the building that
was constructed specifically to hold
them all and to keep them safe from fire
because they were very wearable sorry it
was wood I used to burn down a lot yeah
the idea of wood house this building I
mean not to scare you or anything it's a
lot of wood so by introducing
photography instead of observing through
the telescope you could collect a record
over a period of hours and stars would
show up that couldn't be seen through
the telescope by the eye and then
photographs could be taken all through
the night overtime and you could study a
series of photographs to watch how the
stars changed over time so all of this
kind of work was new and that's why they
needed so many women to be looking at
the place let me see the next slide yeah
go ahead
yeah and what's kind of amazing about
this this story that Dave is talking
about is that we this is actually the
record that we have a hundred years ago
of looking back at the sky itself so
even though we're looking at archival
material this is still very relevant
imagery because this is the you know
kind of the birth of photography itself
the some of the very first images of the
sky were taken with the the Draper's and
at Harvard of different objects but it
also is still relevant
now when new objects or discs
it pays to look back at the Harvard
record what was in that part of the sky
hundred years ago and variable stars was
one of the most important discoveries
that came out of this incredible
catalogue of information so can you tell
me about this this is an actual glass
plate there's an e4 scale right so the
shadow is a penny and those little tiny
strips that you're seeing are the
spectra of all the stars that were
captured on this plate the plates about
eight inches by 10 inches and there's a
prism over the telescope so instead of
seeing the stars as points of light
you're seeing the light spread out into
its component colors but it's a
black-and-white photograph so you don't
see the colors so you just have to know
blue is over here and it varies all the
way to red right and you're looking at
it with a magnifying loupe and you're
seeing the lines that are in the spectra
and from that from the patterns of the
lines creating a classification system
deciphering the chemical composition of
the stars there are so they mean just as
a kind of an aside but one of the most
interesting discoveries which the
discoverer now I can't remember which
one of which one of the women made this
discovery but discover herself didn't
really believe it and that was the
abundance of hydrogen atoms of hydrogen
and who was that okay so the it's
shocking if you look at the composition
of the earth we don't think of hydrogen
as being overwhelmingly abundant but
we're the product of stars having
synthesized heavier elements and spewing
it back out into the the universe to
make you know second and
third-generation material but most of
the universe she realized was still
primordial hydrogen the original stuff I
mean she didn't think about the Big Bang
this is prior to all of that but we now
know when the universe is created it's
mostly just hydrogen you don't have the
means to make carbon and oxygen and
nitrogen until you make stars and this
is a deep discovery that she made an
enema
and her colleagues professional
colleagues dismissed it as right today
people thought the stars the composition
of the stars would match that of the
earth and that the heavy elements would
be more prevalent and the idea that most
of the universe consisted of the two
lightest elements seemed ridiculous but
it took only four years from her paper
until it was and it's by studying the
spectra and noticing that in the spectra
there's evidence of hydrogen absorbing a
particular color let's say or and so you
look at the spectra and you say oh
hydrogen's responsible for eliminating a
particular color in the spectrum and
isn't that how a lot of it was done it's
not fair to say she really knew about
atomic physics yes she studied about
physics and quantum physics yeah so
these early days of quantum where people
didn't know that stars in quantum
physics would be relevant in the
interior of stars in terms of explaining
their histories and what's also
interesting about that is that her
adviser had really discouraged her from
publishing in a way where he said that's
probably not the case and so in your
book where she writes this beautiful PhD
thesis and she's talking about the
abundance of hydrogen and then there's
this one sentence where she says which
is probably not the case yeah it's
probably a spurious result she totally
undermines herself but she does so at
external pressure she at first thought
well this is what I observe well she
questions it - sure so countering to it
but was so interesting as you point out
in your book that it's such a new
subject that it wasn't on you know it
wasn't so far out there for an
astronomer to make a discovery and then
speculate at the same time because
everything was just being discovered at
that time now of course we realized -
she was absolutely right and this again
predates Einstein's predictions that led
to the predictions of the Big Bang
actually I'm not sure exactly the years
it could have been SQUOZE 1916 Einstein
starts talking about general relative
it's pretty clear because surveying is
sort of proposing five
yeah but it's yes so it's close but it's
not in the vernacular of you know
everybody's you know Einstein didn't
believe in the Big Bang even after
people derived it from his own theory so
it's a long time between that and people
starting to understand that the universe
is created and it's very simple and it's
just the most elementary stuff it's
pretty amazing we could see the next
slide and who's this this is Henrietta
Leavitt who was looking at we're going
to get to these magnificent images who
was looking at images taken from South
America because the whole sky had to be
covered there was a second observatory
built in Peru to photograph the stars of
the southern hemisphere and she was
looking at images of the Magellanic
Clouds
and she discovered a couple thousand
variable stars and made a fundamental
discovery about the pattern of variation
that the stars that took the longest
time to go through their cycles tended
to be the brightest stars and she
figured all of the stars she was looking
at were roughly the same distance away
so the ones that looked bright a really
were brighter and that observation led
to the first usable yardstick for
measuring what we would call now
galactic distances and intergalactic
distances in space and her work enabled
the size of the Milky Way to be
determined and maybe getting ahead of
the slides here also that the Milky Way
was not the only galaxy in the universe
that the universe in fact consisted of
multiple galaxies galaxies so it would
be fair to say that at that time they
weren't sure if the universe was maybe
just a few hundred thousand light years
across and maybe that was it that was it
in the shape of the universe like this
led to us looking at you know what
geometry of globular clusters and spiral
galaxies and then to place ourselves
within that geometry let's look at the
next slide I think this will so Leah
tell me about this so this is the plate
that that Henrietta Swan Leavitt was
looking at it's a larger plate most of
the plates are as davis said about eight
and a half by eleven this what is that
it's like ten by fourteen seventeen
seventeen is the they're kind of
standard size 40 by 17 and those
different plates would fit with
different telescopes and here what she's
done is she's overlaid it with a grid
and so this is the small magellanic
cloud so in my tandem research of that
that we were working without knowing
each other I would go out to the Harvard
glass plate archive and look for their
little initials on the cover of these
glass plates so if you can see carefully
the curator had made a little cheat
sheet that had everyone's initials and
so this is the plate that I used as
source material for the next slide
next slide please so this is one of your
pieces right so this is a painting
that's done with ink on a translucent
piece of film and I wanted to not just
make imagery that would reflect what
these women were looking at but that the
process or the final image itself would
reflect their work with the glass plate
so the painting is done on a translucent
piece of paper and then it's used and
will go into the piece of paper it's six
feet by six feet there's two handles
essentially let's point out but we have
a little pop-up show of Leah's work on
the newly built wall here that wall was
painted this morning we do things on
this afternoon it was fans on it we're
drawing it before we tacked Leah's work
up so that is the the piece on the left
is the scale of this piece and we'll get
to how you make the actual physical
piece that's here students let's see the
next slide please
okay that's it that's the one on the
wall over here okay so did we let go in
to process later but this just explained
the philosophy of how
this print is made so the thing that
fascinated me about the glass plate
itself was not just that it was like the
first record of the sky whereas before
if you were a astronomer you had to be a
draftsman so you have make drawings but
then also if I you know say this is a
certain luminosity perhaps David or
Janna might have a different
interpretation of it but that they were
really studying the glass plates and
rarely would they ever print them into
positive so it's like this is a it's a
reference to kind of the evolution of
the photographic process it starts off
with a photographic negative printed
into it's positive but the image was
never photographed and these were their
images of stars but they're printed by
using our Sun the star so it's kind of
multi-layered in its meaning and the
process we'll see some of the process
see and let's see the next slide please
oh there's Leah making a so Leah I
should also say as a artist with a lot
of who leverages science a lot with a
lot of interest in science was a
resident in the science department this
is you can see that's my those are my
equations on the back there and it's
it's now been demolished and it's being
rebuilt as we speak it's pretty amazing
and so there's Leah working in the
science department on a large piece
which becomes the piece on the right so
here you are you're building would you
call this the negative correct yes okay
so let's see the next slide
okay that's us goofing off right this is
okay let's see the next slide and who do
we have here who seems much more tame
than us Leah like we've lost all our
etiquette in a sense of reserve so
that's mrs. Flemming again standing by
one of the cupboards where she keeps her
glass plates and she was there for a
very long time though wasn't she I mean
yes really oversaw the women that were
working did she also oversee any of the
men or were there just two separate
groups she mostly oversaw other women
and
they were out at night taking the
pictures through the chest so they were
operating the telescopes yeah and the
women were doing like the calculations
the calculations and analysis the
photographs really studying the
photographs her she identified an
enormous number of objects is that right
yes yes something unprecedented she
discovered I think 10 novi and hundreds
of variable stars and like the Horsehead
Nebula I think we have a picture of that
well so she had sort of this record of
the most discoveries of variable stars
at the time at the top of the world why
yes exceeded definitely by Miss Leavitt
oh right of course of course okay so
let's see the next slide please
Liat tell me about this yeah so each so
by identifying different plates the
series is that I'm working on is called
your body as a space that season they're
each tied to one discovery that one of
these women made so this is the
Horsehead Nebula
if the Horsehead itself is upside down
and if you look on a contemporary image
of it looks a little bit more horse-like
but this is after Wilhelmina Fleming
which we see the next slide please
oh this is I love this picture and I can
I think we react up over my friend for
finding this picture for me who's here
somewhere
over there in the corner hide Maria
because I know you don't like being
pointed tell me jump cannon in her old
age it looks like she's looking on an
iPad it doesn't what's she doing
it's a glass plate and she has it in the
kind of frames but I used yep it's
correct
that they're very fresh very fragile so
so when you work on them there's always
a danger that they'll break which is why
they're all being digitized now so that
scientists can have access to them
easily and without handling them and
they don't use this process that much
anymore Oh everything yeah it's
completely okay there's this you have a
historical resource it's a hundred years
of the night sky mm-hmm just amazing
next slide please
Oh what do we have here at the
observatory yes this is
the computing room people hard at work
it amazed me what these women endured
because although this was this wonderful
opportunity to contribute to science it
was very difficult commitment it was not
a luxurious commitment this was not a
commitment to an easy life or a life of
any kind of physical comfort I mean they
were poor poor and they suffered all
kinds of illnesses illnesses were were a
real threat and and they worked absurd
hours I mean what did you think about
that uncovering those details
there was deafness gripe what's great
it's cold it's blue the same sorts of
illnesses we have although they epidemic
they they nominally worked regular hours
but then of course anybody who is really
involved in research knows that you
don't stop just because it's five
o'clock or 6 o'clock so they they were
very committed what they gave up was at
the beginning was certainly any kind of
home life mrs. Fleming was unique there
as a working mother as the sole support
of her son and most of the time if a
woman wanted to get married that was the
end of her career so that's that changed
later there is a line right where
someone says something to that effect
that it's no longer the end of your
career once you got married and this was
a big big difference a big change yes
Annie jump cannon and the other thing
about what you're saying about this kind
of long hours is that they're given the
tasks that in a lot of ways is really
just mind numbing of labeling stars and
looking at these spectra but then
they're not given enough time to then
make their own conclusions so for
example would be like Henrietta Leavitt
Swan she discovered Cepheid variables
and as Davis said gives us the the
yardstick to measure the universe but
she's not in a situation where then
she's a research
then to make the jump that we'll get to
what this implies later on in our talk
to really take over as the discoverer
the slide before this Annie jump cannon
on the other hand when she's hired she's
solely unique because she's hired not
only as a computer but she's also hired
to work the telescope at night and ends
up down in arequipa peru and is you know
physically writing about you know how
heavy the telescope is and pushing it
around and playing with the lenses I
mean it's pretty it's different than
most of the other computers and you
sense a frustration that they don't have
the opportunity to extend their work
that they kind of there's a sense that
they they know that there's a great
volume of material but also some
implications some important consequences
and you get the sense that they feel
this frustration of not being able to
pursue it I'm not so sure I mean that's
certainly the retrospective view way
felt I'm not sure they felt that yeah
it's interesting is I I did really
admire that in your book you do not try
to impose the lens of the present no on
the past and you just take it as it is
and and I think that's what gives the
certain moments in the book of clarity
when these women speak in their own
words and in the journals so much impact
because you haven't colored it at all
you know you haven't you haven't diluted
the impact of it so that when it comes I
think it's really powerful and I think
when Miss Canon says she goes to that
meeting about spectral classification
and she's the only woman at a table of
men and she writes in her journal that
since I had done most of the world's
work on this subject I had to do most of
the talking
I'm sort of take it in stride and just
while we're on Annie jump cannon she
says just this is a little bit out of
context because she's she's really
talking about after a kind of personal
trauma but she says may I be led into a
useful busy life I am not afraid of work
I long for it oh it's really you know
and and I think I was gonna say that ad
just this idea of recognition versus
participation and in the beginning of
the observatory Pickering actually puts
out an ad and he gets just endless
responses from educated women who've
just gotten out of college who are
willing to come to the observatory and
are basically begging to work for for
free not 25 cents an hour but for free
and so this I think the kind of veil or
context of adding recognition of
discovery but they just wanted to work
mm-hmm they just wanted to work and to
contribute next slide please
this is uh that's mariah mitchell
amazing let's have a very mature so she
was not one of the no she earlier so she
discovered a comet in 1847 which made
her world famous she looks like she's
about to take it off its stand and swing
it
so when Matthew Vassar started Vassar
College he hired her as professor of
astronomy and she taught some of the
women who came to work at Harvard now
Mariah Mitchell many people think is an
unsung genius just a true extraordinary
I'm good Araya Mitchell she started as a
computed computing work for the coast
survey hmm interesting and and she was
very admired I got the impression but
yes can we see the next slide is this
the one yeah so these are also these are
students at Wellesley Annie jump cannon
is the third from the right so she was
working in a physics lab that had been
modeled on Pickering's physics lab at
MIT and Annie cannons teacher had been
Pickering student and that's why her
education equipped her to to be the
first woman at the observatory who could
use the telescope as well as be a
compute
and I think it's important here since
it's come up a number of times to
acknowledge the impact of the women's
colleges I mean this is incredibly
impactful and Pickering knew it he
thought very highly of the women's
colleges and there was a lot of
aggression against them and and he would
say all you have to do is look at what
these women are producing to understand
the impact if people just knew they
could just see the contributions that
they're making to science that people
would understand the importance of
women's colleges and to add the context
of time and what was going on in the
world at this point when he's hiring the
computers we're still 40 years before
women get the right to vote I mean
that's just mind-blowing you know at
that you know forty years before women
vote there's a room of 20 women at the
Harvard Observatory doing physics it's
pretty incredible I'd like to see the
book that tells us how we went from
there to where we were in like the 70s
and early 80's we're getting better but
how did that happen okay that's a whole
other story we'll talk about it talk
about that over wine over stairs get the
next slide please
trying to keep my eye on the time oh so
this is Peru this is the rudimentary
first Observatory near the town of
arequipa and that's at a later stage in
the shadow of a volcano they thought was
extinct no this is let's get to the non
extinct volcano but but the reason why
this is relevant is because this was
built by this was built the Harvard
group with with a wonderful endowment
that he was able to secure and it
enabled the photography of the southern
sky and what how problematic has the
volcano been well they lost the weather
or after a certain number of years and
Eric capo which had been perfect just
the rainy season got longer and longer
and so they moved everything to South
Africa and sorry Leo I just also want to
point out that when you said that this
was because of a donation it was because
of a donation from a Sepp
a female donor so that was a really
another totally bizarre part of the
lineage of the Harvard Observatory is
that it was run by women it was also
funded by women
this was mrs. Bruce right name is
katherine wolff Bruce paid for the
telescope which I think we have it next
slide we're gonna go out of order can we
go one here this is that's just one more
one more don't mind us in that we were
just so having this sight Pickering
wanted a new much larger telescope he
said he needed fifty thousand dollars
and she came forward and wrote him a
check you know he also spent some of his
own wallet he often the observatory just
increase or to keep things going okay
can we go back James just to the picnic
scene here we go yeah tell me about the
picnic in Peru Solan Bay Bailey and his
wife Ruth are there they really started
the place and I think your next picture
is a globular cluster yes what he was in
she became very interested in these
globular clusters of stars it's the
technical term like a big glob of stars
and he noticed that they were full of
variable stars which he was interested
in so in the close-up picture he and his
wife would try to count the number of
stars in each cluster when they got
close to the center it was impossible
but then they were also looking at
pictures of the same clusters over time
to see the variation can you just tell
is this one of the plates this image I
think this is a glass plate yeah this is
one place and the it's interesting
because until they could really
understand distances two things they
couldn't really know where these
globular clusters are now we know that
they there are some in our galaxy and
there's some and other galaxies as well
but the ones that we're looking at here
is in our own galaxy and it's a
collection of stars that orbit sort of
oddly you know if you imagine our galaxy
is kind of a plane with a spiral
globular clusters live a little more
freely than that they're not as bound to
the plane and and but how would you know
looking at this whether it was in your
own galaxy or it was incredibly far away
I mean their pinpoints right you see no
extension in space of the Stars so you
can't you can't tell by that so how
would you tell them this is why it was
so important as you were mentoring
mentioning with Henrietta Swan Leavitt
that that she gave us a way to gauge the
distance to those objects can you see
the next image please and this is
actually I decided to throw this and
this is a globular cluster has taken by
the Hubble Space Telescope so we we do a
little better now we can see tremendous
detail but you think about the time
scale between the when these women were
working Hubble who will come to after
whom the telescope is named was in the
early 1920s did some of his most
impactful work and then the satellite is
launched you know a few decades several
decades later and it's really quite
extraordinarily short scale really to
think about going from where they were
with these glass plates to launching an
object into space or even saying like is
this object in our galaxy like when they
started doing their study of the glass
plates we didn't know what a galaxy was
I'm sure the definition of galaxy and
what that even could possibly be is also
there was a real idea floated that our
galaxy was the entire universe that's
all that there was and of course now we
know there's as many galaxies in our
observable universe as there are stars
in our own galaxy I mean that's a pretty
big leap can we see you next slide one
more we've done the telescope Leah tell
me about this so this is one of the most
interesting parts of the plates is the
actual notation of the that the women
would use India ink on top of the glass
plate so David mentioned that they're
undergoing a process to scan each of the
glass plates so what they're doing is
they're photographing all of this
beautiful like calligraphy almost on top
of it where there's different things
from numbering systems to classification
of heats and and then what they're doing
is they're scraping the plates and
photographing them so Harvard looks at
this as an arc
of astronomy not as an archive of the
story of the women at Harvard and how
delicate are the plates when you've
handled them are you incredibly
anxiety-producing ly precious or lutely
yeah I mean you're also looking if
somebody breathing down your neck while
you're in the room played no they show
you very carefully you don't touch the
plate you basically you can see that the
sleeve all the sleeves for the most part
are original and that's why you can see
different some of them are extraordinary
actually the sleeves themselves have
beautiful writing of conversations back
and forth of different women and
different writing back and forth so the
next slide please so this is part of
digging into the process of how you make
these in response to the plates right so
this is based on one of the nebula that
I found in the plate and painted
upstairs on the third floor and then
Percy saw those pictures yes sunny
California and printed with my one of my
studio assistant Natalie is here can we
see the next slide while you talk we'll
just look at some of these yeah so we
are doing art here everyone this is the
mixing that chemistry for the sanno
types so we take the studio and turn it
into a darkroom blocking everything out
and mixing photo emulsion and then
coating it on essentially large-scale
watercolor paper
next slide please well used here we go
yep set the emulsion yeah we've turned
on the lights for the sake of the photo
for the photograph that would be a bad
thing to do yes you basically turn we
turn the studio into a dark room you can
go to the next layer and then the
negative is then pressed in between this
kind of painting of photo emulsion on a
watercolor piece of paper press between
glass legs in the next slide and then
it's exposed out in the Sun and so go to
the next one you get these big baths of
you know see an o-type emulsion and i've
been with you and you've been testing
chemicals in this way in this very spot
and you you go through a lot of
different
recipes for the emotions not just like
you mix it and you're done right and
there's a store-bought one and you kind
of compare it against and how do you
come to decide which is the right one
when you've hit the right recipe the the
first print that we did was the piece
here on the left of the small Magellanic
Cloud and I think we were printing every
Friday for almost three months before we
got the very first usable print and also
the Sun moves so the print that you the
exposure time that you use at noon in
the summer in Los Angeles is different
than the exposure time that you would
use in the winter and so the window is
actually very small and changes
throughout the day so you know an
exposure time of 8 minutes becomes 20
minutes when you move 2 hours into the
afternoon and you have to experiment
with all of that next slide please
and this is the piece on the wall that's
right okay so this is the print you you
know you declare as the final print
right so each of the prints themselves
are kind of two paintings and they're
unique so even if it's a photographic
print I can make another one by using
the negative each one might have you can
see especially like around the edges
that there's you know in in the dark
it's very hard to figure out if the
emotion emulsion is on uniformly so I
kind of like that that the painting
itself has a lot of nebulous activity in
it and so does the painting and
sometimes we kind of can't tell is that
the background emulsion or is it the
painting itself and you often exhibit
the negative and the positive side by
side yeah is there what sort of defines
that choice if you decide to show the
negative or not is it if you're thinking
more about process and part of an
exhibition as opposed to final product
and we process seems really important
and this works yeah and I think that
it's not just important in terms of an
artistic process but I think it
highlights the the history of this
project I'm not a historian so I'm so
glad to find out that David was writing
this amazing account of these women
while I was thinking of that was your
meeting was a really happy happy time
for both of us
I have to tell how I was in the archives
and I was meeting a an astronomer
they're very well known astronomer oh
and ginger itch and he said well you've
got to read Davis Sobel's unpublished
manuscript of this story and I thought
well how is that gonna happen
there's no way sure enough you got to
read the yeah and actually Owen was
Cecilia Payne's
student so there is a physicist at
Harvard now who was Cecilia Payne's
you know was one of her PhD students
it's absolutely an incredible lineage
that's sort of like hidden in plain view
you know everyone kind of knows that
there were women there but maybe not
actually understands the full impact of
what the yeah I guess I've had women at
Harvard say to me that they knew that
there had been some women working there
but they always thought it was some kind
of cute quaint story they didn't realize
they were actually doing science yeah
this is interesting as a scientist named
being educated as a scientist I did not
know this story really until alia
brought it to my attention I'd kind of
heard of Pickering's harem and I had
that sort of silly version you know
which is which is pretty amusing and
that's why it gets passed on but it
really wasn't until Leah's work that I
became interested and started to learn a
lot more about this I really did not
know about it and so I think that's
interesting just the idea of education
and why can't we be educated in parallel
as scientists or historians or writers
to have the bigger picture at all times
it's something that we're not doing
right I think and I also think it's
interesting I also have found other
scientists at Harvard who kind of had
the same reaction that you did like kind
of knew it was there but I didn't really
know what it was which is actually
really astounding because the glass
plates are these physical things it's
not just this story but we have this
amazing physical you know lineage to
this story that takes up three stories
that if you were a PhD student at
Harvard you'd walk by the door that says
astronomical archive and so you know
that people are dying yeah I spend a lot
of time at the Center for Astrophysics
at Harvard when I was a graduate student
at MIT and I saw all those pictures
Vantage hadn't been even register
you know who's Annie jump cannon like I
didn't even register and I was
at Harvard for about a week in November
no son I was like oh my god there's a
picture I'm sure it's been up there
since I was in grad school I mean it's
that's pretty dusty didn't look new so
it's just funny that I didn't even
really notice even in the fiber of the
fabric of the buildings that I haunted I
went there almost every day for years
next slide please
hell it's here let's didn't we call this
the paper doll doll yeah so there they
all are
Henrietta Leavitt is on this side with
it with the black Annie jump cannon is
all in white
I hope so with a similar bow but not
it's dark and so this was just the staff
out for a for a lark kind of posed
photos you might like your picture with
Janna sure it will be equally famous one
day yes next slide please
and we were talking about these books in
the context of that photo these are the
record books people people wrote down
what they were doing what they were
looking at you use these how did you use
this I was looking at the handwriting
you know I mean I was in a lot of ways
was directed to some of the specific
plates that different women were using
but I was just you know interested in
any kind of physical imagery like I was
mentioning there Annie's archives are in
the different library and those are
actually her notebooks and her journals
some Christmas cards but then in the the
records you can also see these just like
endless note-taking with their initials
on all these things and I just think
that this that linked to that the
lineage is really powerful to see the
visual replication of all of this
writing in in addition to the glass
plates there's also very extensive card
catalogs that had that mapped the entire
sky I mean the the project itself
basically Draper was looking to
photograph the entire sky I mean that
was a really incredible undertaking so
not just that they were taking these
glass plates and numbering stars but
they were
Bing but he has higher skies south pole
in North and South Hemisphere and just
to connect the pieces he dies
prematurely and it's his wife who funds
the computers at the observatory ever
after so he his dream has sort of
realized but without him next slide
this also I'm thinking my friend Maria
who's hiding in the audience for this I
believe where you check this it's of a
glass plate but it was taken by her
iPhone of the glass plate and this looks
like Andromeda but we think it was taken
by who do you think was taking who he
thinks I get Maria who do you think took
this plate Annie jump cannon but it's
Andromeda which is a near neighbor
galaxy the nearest spiral galaxy to us
it's much bigger than our galaxy but
again we're not I'm not sure exactly the
year of this plate so we don't know if
at the time Annie jump cannon knew that
these galaxies were entire collections
of hundreds of billions of stars and
that they were some millions of
light-years away and an entire other
Island universes as they would have been
called that next slide so this is Hubble
this is the difference right in terms of
the obscurity of the women and and the
acclaim so here's Hubble is an
incredibly famous astronomer this is
probably in early 1920s
Hubble's an interesting character we
won't go into Hubble but he is charming
um even with his fake British accent
because he was an Anglophile but he was
working in Mount Wilson which sort of
looms above Pasadena and Caltech with
some of the most powerful telescopes at
the time and he was in pursuit of these
nebulae that may or may not have been in
our own galaxy next slide I love this
image this is a negative image that
Hubble took at Mount Wilson and it's
dated six of October 1923 and it's
really a dramatic moment David do you
want to talk about this at all
so most of the stars you are seeing are
foreground stars in this picture but he
was identifying stars that were part of
this
nebula and notice at first he thought
he'd found the Nova up top word says and
but then he realized it was a variable
star and it was one of miss Levites
type of variable stars so with that he
was able to tell the distance of the
andromeda nebula and that put it far
outside the Milky Way and that was the
proof that the Milky Way was not the sum
total of the universe so by using Levitz
work he expands the universe from few
hundred thousand light-years suddenly to
millions and now we know it's 90 some
billion light-years across as far as the
eye can see and possibly beyond and that
it's full of these absurd this is also
Andromeda which is the relevance of the
previous glass plate that they were
capturing images of Andromeda as well
and and this is really the moment of the
huge discovery the universe is huge
there are other galaxies and not only
that but the universe is expanding and
it all relies on Levitz were yeah and I
also think this kind of circles back to
this idea where these women are able to
kind of create the data or the
information but then they're not given
time to do the research and make their
own conclusions
so Leavitt is actually the the
Observatory gets a letter that someone
wants to nominate her for the Nobel
Prize but he doesn't realize that she
passed away five years before and at
that time it was shapely who was the
director I believe and he wrote that
basically if if given the time that she
would have possibly come to her own
conclusions but she went on to kind of
hand over the yardstick and then kind of
walk away she handed over was pretty
thoroughly analyzed so it wasn't just
that she had cataloged the information
she really had discovered a mathematical
law that was allowed her so she did this
tremendous analysis in and of its own
right and yes maybe she would have gone
on to then know how to leverage it as a
discovery which has been known as the
period-luminosity relation more and more
people are now calling it the Leavitt
law
yeah these are interesting sociological
details next next slide please
and here is it's not my favorite
photograph of Andromeda but this is the
Hubble Space Telescope's picture of
Andromeda and it's very it's a lot of
color I'm not so sure I kind of like
looking at them in the black and white
but it's a spectacular it's a very big
galaxy it's about a thousand times
bigger than ours
but one day we'll merge so we'll all be
one big galaxy one day and a few billion
years next slide so just on our closing
slide was there anyone in this image you
really wanted to identify that we missed
well we haven't spoken about miss mori
but or down on the floor as Margaret
Harwood she was the first one to come to
the observatory
and then have a fellowship named for
Mariah Mitchell and she went to work at
Mariah Mitchell's own Observatory on
Nantucket and she was the director there
for 40 years Lea we you have favorites
in this crowd is Annie jump cannon sort
of your favorite yeah I think because of
her adventurous spirit but David
mentioned Antonia Morey and it's
interesting about her is that she was
mrs. Draper's niece and she kind of came
in and out of working for the for the
observatory but we had a family tied to
the donor who was a you know let all of
these women work there just correct me
if I'm wrong about this but wasn't
Pickering uncomfortable about paying her
solo a salary because of her he did have
that reaction to think he almost didn't
want to hire her because he he knew he'd
be paying her 25 cents an hour and he
thought that was not right but
Wilhelmina Fleming over so everyone 25
cents was fine right just just to close
before we open for questions I wanted to
read this quote which is from Mariah
Mitchell who was as we said not one of
the Harvard computers but incredibly
influential and she said and this is at
the age of 36 and again I'm borrowing
from my friend Maria who gave me this
two-bit
the best that can be said of my life so
far is that it has been industrious and
the best that can be said of me is that
I have not pretended to what I was not
and I thought that was a very sort of
lovely summery of I wonder a lot of the
the sentiments of the women in
Pickering's harem definitely industrious
you know and unpretentious
yeah and you know they found a way to be
who they really were I mean I don't know
you know let's not get it beyond
ourselves but just to accept that
despite certain limitations or maybe
even because of them you know maybe even
because they didn't have other
opportunities they found a way to do
something that was of their choice and
they were leaning full
yeah and they created a community in and
of themselves that was so it was just
really the the sense of sharing and
experience and the accounts of them you
know not only just getting together
socially but you know doing poetry
readings about the night sky and I mean
it's it's just a really beautiful story
so on that note let's thank our guests
and we'll open up for questions
[Applause]
[Music]
floating around so if you have a
question wave frantically to somebody
who has a microphone over here either if
I could do two quick questions the first
is these women worked very hard with
their eyes did they develop visual
problems yes miss boy is the only one on
record who had to get eyeglasses and the
midst of her work but it's you can see
just from looking at some of the plates
how what a strain that would be my other
question is have you figured out where
you're gonna go to see the total eclipse
of the Sun in August Jackson Hole
Wyoming
[Laughter]
and there's a question up in front and
then behind second row Sakhalin yeah so
listening to this I'm beginning to
wonder what happened to the men because
what I hear is and what I read in the
book these women actually had everything
they really enjoyed their work and they
cooked a lot of recognition from
bickering and shuffling and they really
tried to give them the recognition so I
think they got a recognition the only
thing that didn't get was money right so
now I have about the men that did this
did they get your cognition are you
asking were there men a tall order
did they make more money they did make
more money yeah the men were the
telescope operators did they also get
recognition and sort of career
advancement through their work in the
observatory I mean were there famous men
yes coming out not so much as computers
but being able to make those photographs
was very exacting so those people were
well known Solon Bailey the one who
opened did all the reconnaissance work
to find the place in South America he
published widely yeah the men the men
were well known - yeah burns are some
crazy theories though was it Bailey who
had a crazy theory that he just would
not give up on it was Pickering's we
were viewing the moon and observing
vegetation vegetation on the moon
Martian canals
yeah it's of water on the moon yeah
there's a little over exuberance in the
theorizing yeah in the second row um you
mentioned you hadn't learned about this
and you're training to become a
scientist and I'm wondering if there's
any sort of move in a QT there's sort of
a meme out there to find women in stem
now but is there any sort of systemic
change in curricula and in science
curricula in high school and um oh I
definitely don't know about high school
I didn't study science in high school so
I don't know either from firsthand
experience or from
professional experience but I don't
think there's a change in curriculum but
I think what is important is that books
like this are being published and and
that they're being widely received
because you know the education can't
just be limited to technical classroom I
think we have to start to have a greater
appreciation of the impact of science on
culture and I think this is very much
you know our mission here at pioneer
works by building a science department
in this context it's very intentional
that it's in this context and so I think
that social you know we're changing in a
more important way maybe then the
specific curriculum which is that we're
thinking more about who we are in the
world and we're using a scientific lens
I think to understand a lot of that I
know there's some professors here from
Columbia do you feel like speaking to
that Joe know the issue of whether the
curriculum has been changing over the
years well I will say that a professor
in astronomy from Columbia and also
Jacqueline vanwoerkom previously also a
famous astronomer from Columbia I do
think their astronomy textbooks of today
are quite a bit more historically
conscious for example Henriette live
leave it is credited in all all the
textbooks and I haven't seen the actual
sort of phrase Lea leave it's law but
there's always the linear relationship
and it's always shown and it's
considered the the discovery of
essentially the distance scale of the
universe out to the local group and a
little bit beyond so the local group
being the group of galaxies that are
sort of clustered - yeah there's several
hundred galaxies that are kind of it
marauding around the universe together
you know menagerie yeah so let me ask
another question here now I believe that
this the Cure they're curating of the
Harvard plates actually remained
virtually all female enterprise
throughout the 20th century and maybe
even to this very day the current
curator is a woman has been for a long
time I believe all all curators until
now have all of all been women I believe
maybe MIT and Harvard so yeah so how is
that and you
I mean because have been many directors
it cost money to to run this operation
and I know from experience that a lot of
Harvard professors when it comes time to
shave off the budget they point to the
place tax and say what are they doing
here well mrs. Draper not only paid for
the work during her lifetime but she
provided for the continuation and the
preservation of the plates in her will
so part of the money is still coming
from her that's and also they're just
there hasn't been very many curators I
think there's it's it starts with
Wilhelmina Fleming any Jim cannon and
then two others and now on to the number
five so in this entire lineage that
you're looking at it's actually a small
number of women do we have another could
one more question yeah I think we have
time for maybe two more questions one in
the back okay how long does it take to
read one of the plates to read them you
mean for one of the astronomers when
they first collected plate they they
were never fully read because this the
density of information is so great that
I don't think anyone felt that they'd
been completely plumbed so let's say we
look at one of the plates that was
marked up in great detail the one with
the penny on it how long did that he
taken to mark it up in that great detail
I don't know that I could answer that
but also they may be someone marked it
up and then ten years later they said oh
there's a Nova or there's a variable
star well let's go back ten years let's
check this part of the sky and then they
different questions were asked at
different times and so the same plate
might yield ten answers or sparked no
this six research projects I don't I
don't know that that question is
answerable was it lucidly at harvard
that the plates were used was it nowhere
else in the world that there were glass
plates Oh Mount Wilson had a plate fault
but many people came from Europe and
spent months at Harvard
just because of the plate collection it
was it was a magnet that's why miss
Payne came that was the draw for her
that and the fact that she could could
have a future in astronomy in this
country we have last question here and
then we've got one there and then we'll
come around to the front yes please
sorry this is question four for Leah the
artist in the group if you look at most
of Contemporary Art the great museums in
the world
most of the subject subject matter that
artists concentrate on has to do with
the physical world that we can see on a
terrestrial manner bowls of fruit
landscapes people what is it that gave
rise to this this view point towards the
terrestrial and the extra-terrestrial
rather and the second part of the
question would be that is there a
connection between the notion of the
feminine and the cosmic great question
light one for Leah here well I think
that the the when I think about the
absolute fundamental connection of art
and science
it's the fascination of nature and the
desire to replicate it or understand it
in some way so five hundred years ago
that might have been make a painting of
something and now we have the the
advanced technology of the Hubble Space
Telescope but I think that there's
always been a fascination with the sky
but also a horror of the sky I mean if
you know hundreds of years ago you see a
comet you didn't know what it's coming
or in Eclipse it could actually be
produce notions of the sublime of terror
in a lot of ways so I think that the
notion of of representing this guy that
hasn't been in the lineage of of art
history is is in a lot of ways because
of the lack of technology and as we get
closer to the stars with our you know
the newest telescopes or the LIGO
machine you know measuring gravitational
waves we're going to have different
entry points of how to represent
and get in touch with these with you
know the objects in the sky Dave and I
spent the afternoon at MoMA today and we
were talking about there's a really
incredible painting that I think you
would be interested in the Palazzo Pitti
that had it's a it's dated 1492 but in
the sky there is a there's a UFO and
they've they've x-rayed it and in it's
not only a UFO because I think it for a
long time they thought someone
definitely has come back you know
hundred years ago and added this UFO but
in the painting there's a figure that's
looking and pointing at the sky so
whether that's like a an idea of being
visited but I mean you know but I think
the you know even Giotto has frescoes of
you know representing this guy it just I
think it created a lot of mystery and
awe in in humankind mm-hmm I sorry was
there a follow-up - mmhmm right I think
for me the the relationship to the the
idea of experience and the that to me is
I think a universal experience but in a
lot of ways feminine one I think of one
last question up in the front
it was just a question about the
digitizing of the glass plates when is
that project like slated to be finished
and is will that be accessible to the
public will that be part of the archive
it will be accessible to the public yeah
it will all be online some of the images
already are the the project had a little
hiccup about a year ago when the plate
stacks were flooded and all the
digitizing equipment was drowned but it
has been rebuilt and carrying forward
it's been going on about ten years and I
think they probably need another five to
ten maybe less I'm not sure how quickly
they're going now and I mean it kind of
makes me wonder and this is theirs this
is just wide speculation but to Joe's
point about when someone in the
Astronomy Department at Harvard needs
space and they point to three stories of
metal cabinets of glass plates what's
going to happen once this archive is
completed as weather is so some of the
plates have just beautiful writing on
them or wonderful notation and those
have been set aside but they're such a
small amount that have been set aside
and essentially they're photographing
the covers photographing the notations
and then razoring those glass plates and
scanning them so that someone can go
online and use them it's just a
reference of what the sky was like a
hundred years ago so is it going to be
necessary to have these physical plates
in the future when you said that they're
scraping them they're ruining them for
the sake of digitizing them there see
yeah so you saw so they're destroying
the original yes not not the image but
the writing on them so when the women
would put numbers or other marks on the
plate that has to be washed off before
they digitize and there and the reason
for that is you saw the vast notation on
some of these slides if you're looking
for a star now and you want to see was
there anova I mean you can't see
underneath you know number one through
two thousand and whatever so they're
scraping not the emulsion side of
the photographic image but the side that
the opposite side which is where the
women would write the notation
presumably there is some way though of
digitally looking at an image and
separating out the notation from the
original why don't they scale the
photograph them with the notation okay
that's how they claim them right and
then they scan them and then they record
them but still it's very interesting I
know we have to wrap up but it's very
interesting that the physicality the
plates is extremely inspiring to you and
I'm not a Luddite I'm all right the
digitisation and the all of that
wonderful but you would not have worked
with your process had it not been for
the physicality of their process which
really defined you know your work isn't
just the final thing on the wall your
work is the actual act of going through
having the sun exposure which she
describes it about it's the light of a
star that that makes these images yeah I
mean the that they're exposed by a star
to create them yeah I mean in my own
work I think the process highlights the
history which is essential but that I
don't know there's something in the the
physical link of imagining them it's not
just a romantic notion but that again
the way that we contextualize what these
historic objects are that Harvard looks
at them as an astronomical archive if
you go to a different part of a
different library then they look at
Annie jump cannon x' scrapbooks as the
lineage of Annie jump cannon but the
astronomy department at Harvard doesn't
see that and I'm hoping that David's
book it's gonna make so everyone so
excited about this history that they'll
never think of scraping another plate
this is this is interesting to me
because you're seeing it's also it was
very important drawing you to the topic
as a writer the physicality of the
plates that that they have retained
their value after all this time that was
fascinating how did you even discover
the project through Wendy Friedman
famous astronomer I was interviewing her
and she mentioned the importance of
Henrietta Leavitt in her work and then
when I went to learn more about
Henrietta
but I found that whole roomful of women
which is very surprising mm-hmm
well that's a beautiful place to close
and right before we take a minute yes
we're gonna applaud right before you
take a minute to think I guess I want to
remind you we're gonna have a book
signing that the astronomers are outside
I believe they're still boos at the desk
so please stay and enjoy yourselves and
let's think our guests
[Applause]